It's New York dead or no, no, it's, it's cyclical. It's going to come back new.
York's the greatest city in the world.
There's a lot of things that make it great. Uh,
it's always been a city that's kind of reinvented. There's a lot of new blood.
This will be a very hard rough period. That'll push it to the brink of collapse.
The real estate prices will drop new people will come in and in three or four
years,
you'll have a bunch of young kids that come in that don't want to hear about
Donald Trump. They don't wanna hear about COVID.
They're gonna start doing goofy comedy and playing guitars and wearing funny
hats. And then they're, they're all going to be millionaires.
And that's just what it is.
And then they're gonna open up grilled cheese shops and coffee houses,
and it's just going to be like cyclical.
And you're just going to get sick of it. But for the time being,
you're in a desert for the time being,
I'm living two hours from Los Angeles in an undisclosed location,
the desert and, uh, and it's beautiful. I enjoy, uh, Palm Springs. Uh,
it is, uh, 117 degrees. It kind keeps, uh,
diluting down. It keeps saying it out. Yeah.
We were talking. You were saying,
the place you want to live right now is a place that otherwise would be
unconducive for humanity to reside. Yeah.
I live on the surface of Mars essentially. I mean, it's red rocks all around me.
The desert's hot. I have a big lizard that lives in my house.
There's nothing even burned down over there.
Now. There's nothing in those statutes.
To work against. Whoever's going to protest like Chris is safe too,
because Guido's in their natural habitat are part of nature and they will keep
the protests out of Bay Ridge. You're not getting into my house because I got,
I got Guido's everywhere on the perimeter and Bay Ridge.
And then I got a crazy Puerto Rican.
That'll put your air conditioner out the window. If you even come close to me,
if you're a woman trying to protest, right. That's what it is. That's you know,
it's nice. It's nice to have that.
It's nice to have just a nice girl around you. That'll just cut you.
That'll just cut a. I like that. We really hope you enjoyed that episode.
Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys,
where things get really wild.